Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 258. Radio aus der Krise könnte man es nennen. Wir machen das heute ausnahmsweise nicht im Berliner Chaos Computer Club, sondern wir machen alles schön Stay at Home und reden auch darüber, was uns sowieso alle beschäftigt, nämlich wie man in den Zeiten von Stay at Home digitale Infrastruktur nutzen kann, um Dinge möglich zu machen, die jetzt eben genau deswegen nicht mehr gehen. Wir reden also darüber, wie der Club oder auch wie die Clubs leben können, wenn man ja keinen Fußball vor die Tür setzen darf. Also nicht gar keinen, aber zumindest nicht so, dass man als Menschen zusammenkommt und zum Beispiel feiert. Das ist auch genau unser erstes Thema. Wir werden vier insgesamt haben heute in der Sendung. Wir sprechen jetzt mit Lutz Leichsenring von United We Stream. Hallo und guten Abend. Wir sprechen heute zuerst mal über das Problem, dass Feiern schwierig geworden ist, weil Menschenansammlungen verboten sind. Das trifft natürlich dann auch die Orte, wo gefeiert wird oder wo getanzt wird, nämlich die Clubs. Da habt ihr euch überlegt, na ja, das kann man auch irgendwie anders machen.
Wie? Na ja, der Hintergrund ist, dass ich seit zehn Jahren der Sprecher bin, der Clubkommission, und wir natürlich in diesem Netzwerk von Clubs und Veranstaltern der Stadt versuchen vor allem aus der Kraft unserer Mitglieder oder unserer Clubs und Veranstalter eben uns gegenseitig zu helfen und uns nicht als Mitbewerber oder Konkurrenten zu sehen. Und gerade in so einer Krise bietet sich das natürlich umso mehr an. Und wir haben uns zusammengetan und haben eine Plattform gegründet, die heißt United We Stream und haben ganz viele andere Partner, wie zum Beispiel Arte, Concert oder Radio 1, mit an Bord geholt. Und das Ganze eben auch unterstützt von der Initiative Reclaimed Club Culture, sodass es wirklich so ein sehr holokratisch und partnerschaftliches Projekt geworden ist, bei dem jeden Tag ein anderer Club mit seinen Künstlern zusammen streamt.
Wie streamt? Ist es eine Audio-Stream, die ich mir auf die Kopfhörer geben kann, oder gibt es auch eine Video-Inszenierung in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Ja, es ist ein Video-Stream, der auch ziemlich hochqualitativ produziert ist mit X-Kameras. Es ist eine Fernsehqualität, und der wird dann auch über Artekonzert, über alle Kanäle, sowohl über YouTube und Facebook, aber eben auch über die Artekonzertseite, live streamt.
Die Clubs, die denn da mitmachen, also das Hauptproblem ist ja, ich habe einen Club, der Club ist leer, ich bekomme kein Geld mehr. Gibt es da auch eine Art Finanzierungsmodell, oder ist das vor allen Dingen den Leuchtturm hochhalten und sagen, hey, ihr seid zwar nicht bei uns, aber wir sind noch da?
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine der Kernmessages, dass wir sozusagen visualisieren, dass die Clubs leer sind und dass die Künstler aber trotzdem noch da sind und Clubkultur in die Wohnzimmer, in die Quarantäne bringen. Aber ja, wir sammeln auch Spenden und das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert. Also wir haben keine Paywall, sondern wir lassen die Leute selbst entscheiden, wie viel sie spenden möchten. Dafür haben wir betterplace.org, also auch eine seriöse Spendenplattform, als Partner gewonnen und haben tatsächlich in der ersten Woche schon über 250.000 Euro eingesammelt.
Und wie wollt ihr das dann verteilen? Also ist das so gedacht nach Zuschauerzahlen oder es gibt dann so ein solidarisches, jeder der dran ist, kriegt so und so viel oder hat das gar nichts damit zu tun, was auf dem Stream stattfindet, sondern ihr verteilt das einfach unter den Mitgliedern der Clubkommission?
Ja, also natürlich solidarisch. Also da unterstützen die großen Clubs die kleinen und natürlich wird es auch cross gepostet in alle möglichen Kanäle. Ich glaube, wir haben über 70 verschiedene Plattformen, die diesen Stream auch teilen und die Einnahmen werden nach einem sehr komplizierten Prinzip verteilt. Natürlich, die komplizierter, desto fairer natürlich auch. Also das Grundprinzip ist, dass erst mal die Clubs, die da mitmachen und diese Räume bereitstellen und Künstler buchen, dass die was rausbekommen aus diesem Pod. Dann gibt es einen Teil für notleidende Clubs, die dann auch wirklich nachweisen müssen mit ihrem Steuerberater, dass sie gerade hier Finanzierungsprobleme haben und Anträge stellen können. Da gibt es auch eine Jury, die sich das genau anguckt und auch entscheidet. Dann gibt es einen Pod, der so der Feuerwehrtopf ist für 48 Stunden Anträge, wenn irgendwas wirklich kurz vorm Zusammenbruch steht. Und dann haben wir auch noch einen sehr solidarischen Beitrag. Es gehen nämlich auch 10 Prozent der Gesamteinnahmen an die Stiftung Seenotrettung. Und weil wir eben auch denken, dass Solidarität nicht an den Stadtkranzen aufhört, sondern wir es eben auch in ein Projekt zu geben, zukommen lassen wollen, das vielleicht sogar noch in einer viel traumatischen Situation ist.
Das hört sich ja alles sehr ausgeklügelt an. Jetzt, wie ist das denn geregelt? Also ist das an verschiedenen Orten, also wirklich in den Clubs, die leer sind? Jedes Mal wird das Kameraklub in einen neuen Ort geschafft? Oder habt ihr eine Venue, wo dann quasi alles passiert?
Nee, wir waren dann tatsächlich vom Club zu Club und hatten jetzt eben in den ersten sieben Tagen sieben verschiedene Orte, die dann auch entsprechend inszeniert wurden natürlich mit der Lichttechnik und mit also den Raum einfach in seiner in seiner Lehre auch zeigen. Aber da wir verschiedene Kameraeinstellungen haben, sieht man auch den DJ oder die DJ wirklich so, wie wenn man direkt am DJ-Pult steht. Genau, also das Erlebnis ist ganz besonders, denke ich. Aber wir hatten eben Clubs wie Watergate, Tresor, Kartablau, Krisenmühle, also alles, was Berlin zu bieten hat, ist auch bei diesem Stream mit dabei.
Und ist das wirklich also alles, was Berlin zu bieten hat, also wirklich jeder Club oder habt ihr schon so Zugangsbeschränkungen, wo ihr sagt, also die Wohleheide müsste jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt dabei sein?
Also es gibt ja tatsächlich, wir in der Clubkommission arbeiten ja auch an dieser Begrifflichkeit, was Clubkultur bedeutet und haben da auch eine Studie herausgebracht. Und entsprechend schauen wir uns dann schon genau an, was die Orte für eine Ausrichtung haben.
Aber gibt es da harte Kriterien, also sowas wie die Größe? Oder sagt ihr, ihr könnt euch melden und dann gucken wir mal?
Na ja, grundsätzlich ja. Also wir machen es, wir haben auch, also gerade bei den Auszahlkriterien gibt es zum Beispiel einen Größenlimit. Also für uns ist wichtig, dass es, Clubkultur für uns hat so drei Dimensionen. Das ist die Unabhängigkeit, also es sozusagen ein Unternehmen ist, was jetzt nicht staatlich gefördert ist, das ist schon mal ganz wichtig. Und also Kultur, Entrepreneur, dann hast du die Dimension, dass es ein sozialer Raum ist, der sich an eine bestimmte Gruppe richtet, also entweder eine marginalisierte Gruppe oder eine Gruppe rund um ein bestimmtes Musikgenre. Und dann auch die ästhetische Dimension, also dass es ein Club ist, der programmiert ist, der ein eigenes Booking hat und eine eigene Ästhetik, was die Präsenz, was die Bühneninszenierung und so weiter angeht. Also ein Club, die sozusagen auch das Programm kuratieren. Und das schauen wir uns eben auch an, ob das auf die Clubs zutrifft, die sich da bei uns anmelden.
Wie ist das denn für die DJs? Habt ihr da mal Feedback bekommen von den DJs und DJs, wie das ist sozusagen leer zu spielen? Oder ist das sowieso ganz normal im Zeitalter der Insta-Stories, dass es halt egal ist, ob ich von der Crowd spiele oder von der Kamera?
Also ich glaube, die müssen schon richtig Performer sein, weil du kriegst halt null Feedback, wenn du da an der Kanzel stehst. Das muss man schon sagen. Also ich kannte bisher immer nur den anderen Weg. Also ich habe schon gehört, dass YouTube-Stars ziemlich schlecht auf der Bühne sind vor Publikum. Also dass die tollste Klickzahlen haben und zu großen Stars mutieren, aber wenn sie dann mal vor der Bühne stehen, und das lernt man halt wirklich nur sozusagen bottom-up, dass du da wirklich mit auf einer kleinen Bühne anfängst und dir die Interaktion mit dem Publikum lernst, aber dass es jetzt andersrum ist, dass du sozusagen vor leeren Rängen spielst und trotzdem zeigst, dass du Spaß daran hast. Das ist natürlich eine Frage, die müsstest du jetzt einem Künstler stellen.
Ich dachte, ihr habt vielleicht drüber geredet, dass euch mal jemand überfragt hat.
Ja, ich habe natürlich schon mit wechen geredet, aber die sind so ektrisiert von dieser Idee auch, dass jetzt auf einmal irgendwie 5.000 Leute zuschauen gerade.
Okay, das wäre meine nächste Frage nämlich gewesen, wie viele da sozusagen dabei sind.
Ja, wir hatten also jetzt, glaube ich, nach einer Woche um die drei Millionen Unique-User, Unique-Zugriffe, was glaube ich ganz ordentlich ist, dafür, dass wir das von Null quasi gelauncht haben.
Gibt es auch so ein Feedback-Kanal, dass dann Leute sozusagen, keine Ahnung, Social Media irgendwie zurückgeben, wir feiern gerade bei und dann sind sie halt bei dem Club euch im Stream?
Also wir haben jetzt kein Gästebuch eingerichtet, falls du das meinst. Also wir haben tatsächlich, wir haben uns wirklich sehr dezentral organisiert. Klar, kein Mensch trifft sich gerade in Büroräumen. Das heißt, wir haben wirklich tatsächlich WhatsApp-Gruppen, die sich in wiederum kleineren Gruppen wieder organisieren. Wenigst gerade aktuell läuft auch gerade so ein Stream. Da weiß ich, dass zwischen fünf und zehn Leute nichts anderes machen als Social Media. Das heißt, die werden dann auf den verschiedenen Seiten, die für uns cross-posten, unterwegs sein und Fragen von Leuten entgegennehmen, sie aufrufen, zu spenden und die Community aktivieren. Weil wir haben mit Arte natürlich auch einen Partner, der sehr seriös ist und öffentlich-rechtlich. Da können wir z.B. nicht einen ständigen Spenden-Aufruf ins Bild einblenden, also muss das in der Kommentarspalte passieren.
Ich weiß, was gesagt ist, auch wenn ich produzierte mit Fernsehkameras und so, aber das ist ja nur ein Ort. Ich meine, es wird ja anscheinend eine Weile dauern jetzt, dass die Situation ist, darüber nachgedacht, das Publikum damit einzubeziehen. Im Sinne einer riesigen Videokonferenz, wo vielleicht nochmal 50 Leute auf einem Bildschirm zusammen abfeiern können. Oder seid ihr froh, okay, das läuft jetzt erst mal. Wir machen jetzt erst mal nur das.
Ja, das sind auf jeden Fall Ideen, für die wir offen sind. Also wir umwehren uns wohl jetzt auch an uns. VR-Anbieter ist hier herangetreten mit ganz lustigen Ideen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele Leute so eine Brille bei sich rumliegen haben, aber die Zuhörerschaft hier wahrscheinlich mehr als andere. Also wir sind auf jeden Fall super daran, diese Idee, Clubkultur digital erlebbar zu machen, weiter zu denken. Wir denken zum Beispiel jetzt auch gerade an einen Content-Bereich, wo eben auch Wortbeiträge, Diskussionen stattfinden. Die werden dann wahrscheinlich im Vorprogramm laufen, ein, zwei Mal die Woche. Also solche Sachen sind schon in Planung, aber tatsächlich die Idee, so eine Videowand zu haben. Wir wollen natürlich auch auf der anderen Seite müssen wir sehr vorsichtig sein. Wir wollen ja nicht Leute animieren, zu Hause eine Party zu feiern. Und wenn wir dann jetzt so eine Videoeinblendung haben, wo zehn Leute gerade tanzen, wäre das kontraproduktiv.
Nee, das meine ich gar nicht, sondern was, also ich kann jetzt so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Ein Freund hat natürlich eine Party in Anführungszeichen gemacht, der mir gesagt hat, hier kommt ihr in diesen Videokonferenzraum. Und er hatte sich sozusagen aufbereitet als DJ und hat auch so einen kleinen Lichteffekt. Und dann waren dann aber einfach sozusagen 30 Leute einzeln vor ihren einzelnen Rechnern und haben sozusagen dann aber gemeinsam eine Party gemacht.
Ach so, verstehe.
Ja, so was in dem Sinn.
Das habe ich tatsächlich auch schon gesehen. Also das sieht man dann bei Instagram zum Beispiel, wenn die Leute dann so sich selbst fotografieren, wie sie gerade vorm Computer sitzen und es sind auch fünf andere Leute auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen. Also die feiern das schon so ein bisschen zusammen ab. Und ich glaube, ein User hat mir auch geschrieben, dass er irgendwie Geburtstag hatte und das echt ein schöner Anlass war, alle Freunde zusammen zu kriegen zu dem Stream. Also ja, die Leute gehen nicht mehr in den Club an Geburtstag, aber sie feiern dann vorm Computer, ist auch okay.
Es ist ja hier das Chaosradio und wenn jetzt 5000 Leute gleichzeitig ein Video gucken wollen, dann muss ja irgendwo da Technik stehen, die das auch ausliefert. Also gerade wenn es auch dann noch irgendwie in Hochglanz und deswegen vermutlich auch in hoher Auflösung produziert ist. Kannst du dazu was sagen? Habt ihr damit irgendwie direkt was zu tun gehabt oder war das so ein Ding, wo ihr gesagt habt, Hilfe, wir wollen Videos streamen und jetzt macht das irgendjemand für euch?
Ja, wir haben tatsächlich, ich hätte es nicht aus dem Boden stampfen können, so eine Idee, wenn wir nicht da schon Erfahrung hätten und es gibt schon seit jetzt zwei Jahren, glaube ich, eine Veranstaltung, die immer montags im Sommer stattfindet, in der Ibse. Hallo Montag heißt die. Und die hat schon über mehrere Monate, wie gesagt, hinweg mit Art Concert kooperiert und hat quasi die Künstler auch damit so ein bisschen gelockt. Es ist zwar ein Montag und wir können auch keinen Eintritt verlangen, aber wir können euch hier einen richtig geilen Stream zur Verfügung stellen. Und das hat gut funktioniert. Und natürlich war dann Hallo Montag und die Jungs von Sol, von dem Label, dann auch gleich bereit zu sagen, hey, alles für die Solidarität. Wir geben unseren Kontakt hier von Arte mit in die Barschale.
Okay, das heißt, die technische Seite wird komplett von Arte einfach gemacht?
Also von den Jungs von Sol in Zusammenarbeit mit Arte.
Das heißt, über mangelnde Bandbreite müsst ihr euch überhaupt gar keine Sorgen machen?
Naja, die Bandbreite entscheidet sich ja auch vor Ort mit der Internetleitung des Clubs.
Das sind immer so, ja stimmt, Probleme, an die man dann gar nicht denkt. Jetzt ist das ja so, das ist ja, du hast ja auch gerade gesagt, also die DJs sind auch getragen oder elektrisiert von der Idee, dass man das jetzt gerade so macht. Und Leute sind auch erstmal begeistert, weil es eine Alternative ist, weil man darf ja nicht. Was glaubst du, wie lange das hält oder tragen kann? Weil ich mich schon frage, wenn da die Anfangsbegeisterung vorbei ist. Also ich wünsche uns natürlich, dass die Kontakteinschränkungen eher wieder aufgehoben werden, als dass diese Anfangsbegeisterung wieder vorbei ist. Aber glaubst du, dass das sozusagen so weitergeht oder dass man das Format dann weiterentwickeln muss? Oder wird es einfach eine digitale Clubkultur dann geben müssen?
Also wir sind ja jetzt gerade mal zehn Tage live.
Okay, dann lass mich da gleich mal fragen. Diese zehn Tage fühlt sich das immer noch an, als wir haben diese geile Sache jetzt angefangen. Oder ist es schon so, wir machen das schon seit zehn Tagen?
Nee, es fühlt sich krass schon ziemlich lange an. Also wir sind ja schon ein eingespieltes Team und wir wissen, jeden Abend kommt der Stream und so weiter. Ich wage auch gar nicht zu vermuten, wie das jetzt sich anfühlt, wenn wir jetzt erst mal ein, zwei Monate hier alle in Isolation sind. Und ob das dann unser einziger Lichtblick dann noch ist, dass wir dann diesen Stream haben. Ich dachte, also man kann davon ausgehen, dass natürlich jetzt ganz, ganz viele Leute versuchen, mit Streaming ihre Kunst weiterhin zu produzieren. Das ist ja auch alles total legitim und auch toll, dass es diese Möglichkeit gibt. Wir sehen, wo wären wir vor 20 Jahren, wenn so ein Virus ausgebrochen wäre, hätte die Leute mit ihren 56K Modems sich irgendwo eingewählt. Also ich glaube, dass das auf jeden Fall uns jetzt irgendwie weiter bewegen wird, das Thema. Das ist jetzt auch nicht super neu. Schließlich hat es auch schon Boiler Room gegeben vor dieser Geschichte hier. Noch mal ein bisschen anderes Konzept, aber das gab es auf jeden Fall schon.
Musst du mal kurz erklären, also Boiler Room war doch, die haben auch Partys aufgenommen und das dann als Bezahlvideo zur Verfügung gestellt.
Nö, die waren auch kostenlos, haben aber mit Werbepartnern gearbeitet. Und das war im Prinzip eine Party, die immer rund um den DJ, der war im Fokus und wurde auch gefilmt dabei. Ja, also es ist nicht jetzt ein völlig unbekanntes Konzept, so was zu machen. Aber natürlich, was dieses Konzept so spannend macht, ist eben, dass wir in diesen großen Clubs, in denen normalerweise der Schweiß von den Wänden triebt und dann ganz krasse Energie herrscht, jetzt auf einmal leer ist und die Künstler dort auftreten, die auch wirklich hochkarätig sind. Also wir haben Ellen Alien, Penport, wir haben wirklich tolle Künstler da auf der Bühne gehabt. Dass das verbunden auch mit einer sehr hochwertigen Produktion schon was ist, was gewertschätzt wird. Und man nicht denkt, ah ja, da hat jetzt jemand kurz von der Couch in die Küche bewegt oder andersrum und mal kurz die Kamera angemacht.
Was auch Gutes, was auch Gutes, aber nicht sozusagen für die Highgloss Clubparty. Das klingt aber so, das finde ich schon ganz krass, als ob die, als ob das einfach so funktioniert. Also das rund herum klappt. Ich hatte ja gedacht, man kann jetzt fragen, so braucht der noch irgendwo Hilfe, aber das klingt ja wie ein fertiges Ding, wie ein fertiges rundes Ding.
Was man daran sieht auch, dass die Tech-Community auch nicht weit weg ist von der Musik-Community. Also ein Music-Nerd ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so weit entfernt, vor allem Tech-Nerd. Also wenn ich mich mit einer Sache so sehr beschäftige und liebe, was ich da mache und mich auch einschließen kann über mehrere Stunden und Tage, dann gibt es da schon viele Analogien und das merken wir auch, wenn wir zum Beispiel solche Sachen starten, dass da eben auch ganz viele Leute begeistert sind, die auch aus einem ganz anderen Kontext kommen und das eben mögen, dass es eben so eine rebellische Seite auch gibt oder so eine Aktivistenseite in der Musik, die man eben auch aus dem Tech-Kontext kennt.
Na, sehr schön. Dann würde ich noch fragen wollen, was passiert denn so die nächsten Tage bei euch?
Ja, heute Abend sind wir in der Anomalie mit einem ganz fetten Line-Up. Morgen sind wir im Ritter Butzke und dann sind wir im Hör.
Wenn das jemand als Podcast jetzt hört, kann man die auch als Aufzeichnung gucken? Oder ist das sozusagen, es ist live und die Party passiert nur, wenn die Party passiert?
Ja, also tatsächlich ist das rechtliche Thema bei Streaming ja auch nicht so trivial. Man kann in Deutschland, auch glaube ich ganz Europa, bekommt man eigentlich Probleme, wenn man streamt und nicht die Abgaben an der GEMA auch berücksichtigt. Da sind gerade sehr viele, die das machen in so einer Krautzone. Und deswegen haben wir uns auch entschieden, mit Arte zu arbeiten, weil die eben so einen Rahmenvertrag haben mit der GEMA und wir da rechtlich total abgesichert sind. Aber das bedeutet auch, dass wir mit den Videos jetzt nicht alles machen können.
Okay, also das heißt, sie bringt Arte vielleicht irgendwann nochmal, aber es gibt jetzt keine…
Ja, oder sie sind bei YouTube, glaube ich. Bei Arte YouTube-Kanal kann man sie jetzt schon angucken. Aber wir wollen sie eigentlich auch als Archiv mal hinterlegen, da sind wir da auch noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Okay, so wie ist die URL von der Webseite, falls man mal gucken will, was da so geht?
UnitedWeStream.Berlin.
UnitedWeStream.Berlin. Na dann, Lutz, vielen Dank.
Hat mir Spaß gemacht und die halbe Stunde ist schon längst vorbei.
Vielen Dank, viel Spaß euch, gute Party und trotzdem, auch wenn das ein sehr geiles Projekt ist, wünsche ich euch und dir, dass doch bald wieder Leute in den Club kommen können, weil ich glaube, es ist ja dann doch noch mal ein bisschen was anderes. So, das war das erste Thema heute im Chaosradio 258 über alternative Infrastrukturen. Wir sprechen gleich ein bisschen über E-Learning. Vorher eine kleine Musik, die ich entsprechend dem, dass sich die Situation gerade ein bisschen surreal anfühlt, auch surreal ein bisschen ausgesucht habe. TKN ist das, das ist ein japanischer Musiker oder Musikerin. Weiß ich gar nicht so genug, man erfährt aus der Bandcamp-Seite nicht viel. Quest heißt das Album und Gone der Titel, den wir jetzt hören. Gone von TKN hier am Chaosradio 258, wo wir gerade darüber geredet haben, wie man trotz Corona-Krise Party machen kann, ohne an den Partyort zu gehen, nämlich per Stream. Und es geht jetzt vielleicht zum Leidwesenden von Heranwachsenden, aber nicht nur ums Party machen oder zu Hause rumhängen, sondern auch ums Lernen. Und da muss man natürlich auch irgendwie gucken, weil an den Ort des Lernens oder der Lehre darf man auch nicht mehr gehen, wie das digital geht. Und dazu haben wir jetzt Mirco da. Hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo.
So, erklär uns doch erstmal genau, wo du herkommst, was du machst und was davon mit Bildung zu tun hat und warum die digital ist. Also wer bist du?
Mirco, ich arbeite an einer, das ist noch nicht ganz eine Berufsfachschule in Hannover. Das heißt, wir bilden aus, passenderweise im Gesundheitswesen. Das heißt, wir haben Leute da, die bei uns Pflegekräfte werden. Genau und ich betreue da oder administriere da das Lernmanagementsystem.
Was ist ein Lernmanagementsystem?
Genau, ein Lernmanagementsystem ist im Prinzip das, wo jetzt alle irgendwie nach schreien. Also manche haben es natürlich schon oder viele Schulen haben sowas, nutzen es aber in der Form nicht. Also man kann darüber Schulmaterial zur Verfügung stellen. Das ist so die ganz rudimentäre Funktion, die gerade ganz viel genutzt wird. Man kann aber auch viel komplexer damit arbeiten, ganze didaktische Szenarien aufziehen, Aufgaben stellen, Feedback zu den Aufgaben geben, Bewertungen einstellen und den ganzen Lernfortschritt darüber abbilden. Genau, das macht Lernmanagementsystem.
Kannst du das mal an einem Beispiel illustrieren?
Ja klar, also bei uns ist es so, dass die Auszubildenden, die durchlaufen einen Theorie-Teil bei uns in der Akademie und da müssen die natürlich ihr theoretisches Fachwissen erlernen und da gibt es dann ein Curriculum, das gibt es für jedes Fach, in jedem Land auch, also für jedes Fach ein Kerncurriculum, wo Inhalte festgelegt werden, die für das Fach halt relevant sind und jetzt versuchen wir dieses Curriculum in irgendeiner Weise in diesem Lernmanagementsystem abzubilden. Wir haben Kurse in dem Lernmanagementsystem, quasi Klassen und dann pro Klasse gibt es einen Trainer oder einen Betreuer und die stellen dann Informationen zur Verfügung, Aufgaben und so weiter und die Schüler bearbeiten das dann.
Aber ich wollte sagen, die konkrete Frage war so ein bisschen, also klar kann ich mir vorstellen, es gibt eine Plattform, dann melde ich mich an und dann kann ich da runterladen, was in der letzten Unterrichtsstunde gesagt wurde oder eine Aufgabenblatt oder so. Und du sprichst aber von didaktischen Konzepten aus. Ich kann mir auch noch vorstellen, dass man irgendwie einen Multiple Choice Test macht und dann vielleicht auch sogar automatisch seine Notreiche ausgerechnet kriegt.
Ja, also die Pädagogen, die rollen mit den Augen, wenn es dann um Verquissungen und so was geht. Nein, also das sind didaktische Konzepte, das ist jetzt ein schmaler Grad. Also du musst dir das so vorstellen, du hast ja Lernziele für dein Unterricht und du willst idealerweise pro Unterrichtsstunde oder pro Unterrichtseinheit solche gewissen Dinge vermitteln. Und das kannst du jetzt relativ granular sozusagen darüber abbilden. Das heißt, du machst so kleine Elemente, also sowas wie ein Multiple Choice Ding zum Beispiel, ist sowas für eine Ergebnissicherung. Aber vorher musst du denen ja auch erstmal so die, das ganze, die Grundlage sozusagen, denen geben, worüber du die dann prüfst. Und das kannst du darüber dann auch abbilden. Entweder mit kleinen Videos, du kannst jetzt eine Fülle von Material, das du dir aus dem Internet zusammensuchen kannst, da einbinden kannst, in eine komplett in sich geschlossene Lerneinheit.
Aber eine Lerneinheit ist immer was, was die SchülerInnen oder Auszubildenden alleine abarbeiten und es ist nicht ein Unterricht, der stattfindet.
Genau, also klassisch hast du ja viel Präsenzunterricht. Das heißt, die Schüler gehen in die Schule, das, was jetzt nicht geht, und kriegen dann da den Auftrag. Das können die dann entweder im Klassenraum machen, oder es lockert sich ja auch ein bisschen, dass die sich verteilen können. Jetzt hast du natürlich die Situation, dass diese ganzen Methoden, die Lehrer verwenden, die häufig auf Präsenzunterricht ausgerichtet sind, nicht mehr funktionieren. Das heißt, du brauchst andere Methoden. Da gibt es schon sowas wie, also ein Vended Learning Ansatz, Mix das beides, also analog und digital. Flip Classroom ist so ein Begriff, der da häufig verwendet wird. Das heißt, du gibst erst den Input und dann, dann triffst du dich wieder und sprichst dann in der Präsenzzeit über dieses Thema. Jetzt hast du die Situation, dass du alles über das Online-System abbilden musst, was natürlich eine riesige Herausforderung ist. Viele tun sich da jetzt, glaube ich, ein bisschen schwer.
Bevor wir dazu kommen, wie das Verhältnis von Lehrenden auch zu den Tools ist, will ich noch mal fragen wollen, wie das schöne Fachwort Lernstandsüberprüfung ist, also die im Prinzip ja Arbeiten schreiben. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das nochmal eine ganz eigene Herausforderung ist, weil in einem Klassenraum kann man die Leute auseinandersetzen und hingucken, ob jemand schummelt. Ich will jetzt niemandem was unterstellen, aber werden solche Systeme auch darauf hingedacht oder sind die eigentlich für Prüfungssituationen momentan noch überhaupt gar nicht gedacht?
Das kann ich pauschal nicht sagen, also bei uns ist die Situation ja so, dass wir zwischen Prüfung haben und Abschlussprüfung, das heißt, wenn wir jetzt nicht die klassische Klassenarbeit, die abgebildet werden muss. Ich weiß von einer Bekannten aus Hamburg, die machen gerade E-Mail-Klausuren, das heißt, die Aufgaben werden für ihn verschickt zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt und dann zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt müssen die zurück sein. Ein Lernmanagementsystem kann das abbilden, das heißt, man kann Aufgaben freischalten für einen bestimmten Zeitraum. In dieser Zeit muss diese Aufgabe bearbeitet werden und danach ist die Aufgabe nicht mehr verfügbar, das heißt, das, was dann da steht, gilt. Das heißt, es geht und auch die Bewertung kann dann darüber abgebildet werden. Eine andere Frage ist natürlich, inwieweit das von der Landesschulbehörde oder wem auch immer, inwieweit das akzeptiert wird in der Form.
Das ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Was ich hier ja meinte, ist sozusagen, gerade im Umfeld, in dem sich diese Sendung bewegt, also Leute, die Spaß am Gerät haben und gerne Dinge zerforschen, würden ja denken, na also, wenn so eine Lern- fachwort, die Lernschulüberprüfung verlangt ja, dass eine gewisse Person vorm Computer sitzt, aber woher wollt ihr das wissen?
Ja, man kann ja die Zeitung da reinhalten. Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage, die habe ich mir jetzt für unser Szenario nicht bestellt. Weil wir jetzt nicht in der Form prüfende Elemente da drin haben, sondern hergucken, dass die Inhalte vermittelt werden. Und die Prüfung erfolgt dann über hoffentlich wieder analogen Wege. Ja, aber es sind interessante Fragen, super viele interessante Fragen, die sich auf einmal viele Leute stellen. Und jetzt sind die Leute gezwungen, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen und idealerweise coole Antworten zu finden.
Wie ist das denn generell? Also wenn man das Klischee nimmt, dann ist es ja so, die Leute, die sich an Schulen oder Lehr-Einrichtungen mit digitalen Lernkonzepten beschäftigen, sind meistens, also wie gesagt, ich reite zu einem Klischee, idealisierte Einzelkämpfer, die ab und zu mal sagen, hey, sollten wir nicht vielleicht mal, und dann wird im Lehrerkollegium müde abgewunken. Und man macht das aber, weil es ist schon irgendwie, es ist schon irgendwie, also mit dem Internet, also wahrscheinlich wird es nicht mehr weggehen. Aber so richtig will man das dann eigentlich gar nicht und nutzt es dann auch nur so, so weit, wie man herhin getreten wird. Und jetzt ist Zeit der Krise und alle so, ha, wir hatten da noch noch diesen einen Typen, der mal davon geredet hat, dass man es nicht auch digital machen kann. Was macht der eigentlich gerade und kann der nicht eigentlich gestern unser digitales Lernkonzept fertiggeschrieben haben? Wie ist es wirklich?
Ja, also momentan fühle ich mich oder also nicht nur ich alleine, sondern so diejenigen, die es vor mir auch schon gemacht haben, die fühlen sich genau wie die Treter jetzt, die sich bestätig fühlen. Ja, wie gesagt, pauschal kann man das, glaube ich, überhaupt gar nicht sagen. Es gibt super viele Schulen, die halt total am Start sind und komplette, was ist das Wort hier, Niedersachsen Medienentwicklungspläne, das hatten die alles schon, bevor die überhaupt geschrieben werden mussten. Also da gibt es schon ganze Institutionen, die super weit sind. Aber mein Eindruck ist auch, dass, oder anders, also ich freue mich total darüber, dass sich jetzt so viele halt, die eher analog unterwegs sind, darüber Gedanken machen, aber, und das stelle ich auch fest, dass sie das total spannend und interessant finden. Und das jetzt tatsächlich auch mal sich erklären lassen und dann vorbeikommen und hier kannst du noch mal eben einmal gucken und kannst es noch mal zeigen, was halt total so komisch es klingt, aber es ist eine schöne Entwicklung eigentlich. Weil man so ein bisschen das aufbricht, was sich halt so verfestigt hat über die Jahre.
Also sozusagen könnte man das in dieser Krise was Positives sehen und sagen, na ja, das läuft zwar alles gerade etwas unrund, aber es hat uns zumindest mal den Freiraum gegeben, sich überhaupt damit zu beschäftigen, weil das in einem normalen Alltag einfach gar nicht möglich ist.
Absolut, das würde ich total unterstreichen. Also das, was wir jetzt gerade machen, also die Situation, die jetzt erforderlich ist, die Rahmenbedingungen, die Struktur, die wir jetzt eigentlich bräuchten, die wollten wir eigentlich erst innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre entwickeln und komplett knörkelos durchdesignen und so weiter. Und auf einmal brauchen wir sie jetzt schon. Und jetzt müssen wir sie halt so nehmen, wie sie ist. Nämlich halt eben noch nicht ganz rund. Und wir sammeln jetzt da super viele Erfahrungen damit. Nicht nur wir, die das schon ein bisschen länger machen, sondern auch alle anderen Kollegen, die... Wie gesagt, also ich kriege total viel positive Resonanz von, ja.
Also auch von den Lehrenden.
Genau, ja, eigentlich. Mit den Schülern hat mich direkt gar nicht so viel zu tun. Aber ich glaube, für die ist das auch, für die Auszubildenden ist das halt auch angenehm, dass sich da einfach ein bisschen was tut.
Ja, wie ist denn, also gibt es da Probleme, die jetzt aufgetaucht sind, wo du, also ich verstehe, nee andersrum, ich muss jetzt erst mal fragen, ist das jetzt schon so, dass das System, das ihr betreibt, mehr benutzt wird als vorher? Weil ich muss jetzt gerade an Computerspiele denken, da versucht man ja, bevor man sie releaset, alle Fehler rauszumachen und dann findet aber so der erste richtige Produkttest eigentlich nach dem Release erst starten, werden so richtig viele Leute darauf zugreifen. Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, ihr habt dieses System und ja, ihr arbeitet schon lange damit, aber jetzt gerade ist es sozusagen das, wo alle unterwegs sind. Sind da Probleme aufgetaucht, wo ihr gedacht habt, oh, das ist aber interessant, das hätte ich mir so nicht vorgestellt? Oder gibt es einfach nur durch die Menge vielleicht bandbreiten Probleme im weitesten Sinne?
Da müsste man die IT vielleicht nochmal fragen. Die bewertet das Endes vielleicht ein bisschen anders als wir jetzt quasi auf der Anwendungsebene, aber bisher die klassischen Probleme und da greift man sich immer wieder an den Kopf, also Passwörter vergessen oder Zugang funktionieren, solche Sachen, klar, das hast du dann halt. Aber da muss man dazu sagen, ich glaube, da waren wir relativ gut darauf vorbereitet, weil eben Gesundheitswesen, hatte man das schon mal so ein bisschen im Blick, glaube ich, und daraufhin wurde dann so eine Art, ich habe einen Notfallplan entwickelt und das beinhaltete halt, dass sowohl alle Lehrer als auch die Auszubildenden sich nochmal anmelden sollten und dann gucken sollten, funktioniert alles, die Lehrer sollten Unterricht vorbereiten, den sie dann über das Lernmanagementsystem abbilden konnten. Also das hat eigentlich relativ gut funktioniert für diese doch relativ chaotische Situation dann oder Entwicklung.
Die Software, die ihr da benutzt, ist das was handgefertigtes oder ist das was, was mehr oder weniger frei verfügbar ist oder verbreitet sogar?
Also wir nutzen Moodle, das ist glaube ich so das weit verbreitetste Lernmanagementsystem, das ist Open Source, es ist nicht so schön wie andere, aber das ist ja häufig so. Das heißt wir müssen es selber schön machen. Genau und da arbeiten wir jetzt halt auch noch dran, aber das, ja also die ist schon relativ weit verbreitet und auch etabliert schon seit, ich weiß gar nicht, seit wann es so schon geht, aber seit mehr als zehn Jahren auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe die, das ist ja ein Name, der jetzt natürlich auch häufiger fällt und den man aber auch schon gehört haben kann, wenn man sich auch nur irgendwie im digitalen Medienpädagogischen Kontext rumgetrieben hat. Aber eben es gibt jetzt viele Leute, die zum ersten Mal mit diesem System konfrontiert werden. Hast du für die, also sowohl auf der Benutzerinnen- seite als auch auf der lehrenden Seite Tipps, wo man sagen kann, ok dein erstes Mal mit Moodle, wahrscheinlich ist es gut folgende Dinge zu beachten?
Das kommt echt sehr stark darauf an, was du damit machen möchtest. Wenn du einfach nur schnell dir deinen Kurs bespielen möchtest oder deine Klasse, dann reicht es, wenn du deine Materialien einfach so erstellt und die hoch lädst. Also mehr schaffst du jetzt in dieser kurzen Zeit akut halt einfach nicht. Wenn man schon so ein bisschen tiefer drin ist, dann, also was ich halt persönlich sehr, sehr cool finde, ist halt eben übermutig hinauszugehen und mit Autoren-Tools zu arbeiten, weil es einfach so ein bisschen mehr attraktiver oder ein bisschen mehr Möglichkeiten gibt, Inhalte attraktiv aufzubereiten. Und da kann man dann halt viel mit Plugins machen. Aber das ist jetzt auch nichts Spektakuläres.
Was, aber für dich vielleicht nicht, aber was genau bedeutet das? Was sind Autoren-Tools in dem Zusammenhang?
Na, Autoren-Tools, also das kennt man jetzt aus dem beruflichen Weiterbildungs-Kontext. Da hat man ja so ein Webinar oder sowas. Und da sind die Inhalte, wenn sie nicht mit PowerPoint oder mit irgendwas sind, mit einem Autoren-Tool erstellt. Das heißt, es ist relativ in sich geschlossen, geschmeidig und responsive auf allen Geräten. Ja, und sind ein bisschen multimediale Inhalte eingebunden. Und die ganzen Quiz-Formate und so weiter sind dann halt, das lässt sich einfach relativ geschmeidig dann erstellen.
Das ist sozusagen eine Zusatzsoftware für Moodle, die es mir erlaubt, dann Dinge in Moodle zu erstellen. Aber für mich ist dann, also für einen Benutzer oder eine Benutzerin, ist das im Prinzip eine Software aus einem Gust, wenn die ordentlich eingerichtet wurde.
Genau, für den Teilnehmer in dem Kurs sieht das dann am Ende idealerweise einfach nur ein bisschen besser aus. Und du hast halt, also es ist halt einfach ein bisschen, die User Experience ist dann halt einfach ein bisschen geschmeidiger und ein bisschen idealerweise dann auch lernförderlicher, wenn es gut durchdacht ist. Und für den Ersteller solcher Inhalte, es ist halt einfach ein bisschen, bietet oder gibt es da einfach ein bisschen mehr Möglichkeiten, Sachen zu kombinieren, ein Video anzureichern, mit Fragen an den richtigen Stellen, solche Sachen.
Es ist ja leider so, dass es natürlich Leute gibt, die Freude an Technik haben und dann auch ein neues System schnell kennenlernen. Aber auch Leute, die ganz überrascht davon sind, dass es solche Dinge überhaupt gibt und die das dann benutzen müssen. Hältst du das für eine niedrigschwellige Software oder hast du vielleicht einen Tipp für eine Ressource, wo, wenn man gar nicht damit klarkommt, sich das gut erlernen kann? Ja, ich kann nur von anekdotischer Evidenz reden. Eine Heranwachsende in meinem Personenumfeld, da hat die Schule auch gesagt, Moodle hier, super Idee, da kann man da drüber die Materialien wenigstens zur Verfügung stehen. Das hat nicht geklappt, das hat irgendwie zehn Tage gedauert und dann kamen die Materialien per Mail, weil es anscheinend so kompliziert war.
Da gibt es Lernmanagementsysteme, die einfach ein bisschen angenehmer gemacht sind für den nicht ganz so technikaffinen Lehrkörper, sag ich jetzt mal. Idealerweise, oder was ich als Schule, glaube ich, machen würde, ist das einfach ein bisschen aufteilen. Es gibt Leute, die kümmern sich um den ganzen Admin-Kram und Nutzerpflege und solche Sachen. Und dann gibt es eher kreativere, die dann eben mit den Autoren von uns arbeiten. Das ist so meine Herangehensweise.
Aber das ist kein guter Online-Lehrgang. How to Moodle für Lehrkräfte.
Na ja, bei Moodle selber gibt es das Forum, was ich persönlich viel nutze, wo man einfach die ganzen gängigen Probleme, die sind da schon sehr gut dokumentiert. Es gibt natürlich auch Anbieter, die Trainings für Moodle anbieten. Ich hatte neulich noch einen YouTube-Channel gesehen, wo diese ganzen Basics auch in so relativ kleinen Nuggets ganz gut aufbereitet sind. Also die gängigen Recherchewege würde ich da als erstes gehen.
Okay, aber falls dir der YouTube-Kanal nochmal über den Weg läuft, schick ihn uns, wir schreiben es dann in die Show Notes.
Ich kann meine ganzen Leseteilchen gerne einmal überschicken.
Dann gibt es eine große Liste für interessierte Lehrkräfte.
Achso, an der Stelle, ich hatte neulich noch was gelesen, wenn es um Tipps geht für Lehrer, wäre das noch nicht gesehen. Genau, ich meine, ich gucke es nochmal nach und dann kann ich das nachreichen.
Ja, sehr gut. Also die genauen Details in den Show Notes zur Sendung. Jetzt hast du vorhin schon mal ganz kurz erwähnt, dir ist nicht klar, ob das dann anerkannt wird, wenn so Arbeiten darüber gemacht werden. Wie ist das denn generell? Also ich habe selber ein paar Veranstaltungen moderiert, wo es darum ging, wie kann man digitale medienpädagogische Konzepte umsetzen? Oder digitale Konzepte für Pädagogik, muss man sagen, umsetzen. Und der Hemmschuh war dann immer die Politik. Jetzt befinden wir uns ja gerade in einer Situation, die eine Krise ist, aber glücklicherweise erst mal nichts Dramatisches für die einzelne Person bedeutet. Das heißt, es gibt, also solange man gesund bleibt, das heißt, es gibt viel Energie und es wird jetzt eben auch viel gemacht. Und es gibt auch so Grauzonen, wie ist es denn vom Gesetz eigentlich geregelt? Ist all das, was ihr da gerade macht, darf man das eigentlich? Oder ist das momentan so, naja, wir machen jetzt gerade das, was geht, weil anders geht es halt nicht, aber wenn wieder normale Verhältnisse einklären, müssen wir dann mal gucken, ob das überhaupt noch so möglich wäre?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also ich kann das nicht für allgemeinbildende Schulen sagen. Ich weiß für uns, dass unser Weg halt dahin geht, dass wir einen gewissen Prozentteil der theoretischen Ausbildungsinhalte auf jeden Fall über ein Online-Angebot abbilden können. Also wir sprechen da von 5 bis 10 Prozent.
Und mehr dürft ihr eigentlich nicht, oder wie?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit dürfen und können und wollen ist. Das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Das ist auf jeden Fall unser, das, was wir umsetzen wollen. Darüber hinaus können wir natürlich erst mal alles mögliche an Inhalt zur Verfügung stellen. Es muss aber eben diese Balance geben zwischen dem, was noch im Präsenzentritt da ist. Also das ist so unsere Situation. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei allgemeinbildenden Schulen ist. Ich kann mir aber vorstellen, dass die Kultusminister an der Stelle eben auch auf einmal anfangen, sich genau darüber halt eben Gedanken zu machen.
Wie es dann in Zukunft weitergeht oder ob sozusagen diese Situation jetzt ein Vorbild sein kann?
Genau, also die Lessons learn quasi aus digitaler Schule während Corona-Zeiten. Und was kann man davon vielleicht einfach übernehmen und für die Zukunft halt irgendwie sinnvolle Gesetze packen.
Jetzt ist ja ein Problem, das ich zumindest bei mir im Umfeld beachte und ab und zu auch mal davon lese, dass wenn, also das ist bei vielen, das ist jetzt auch wieder allgemein mit den Schulen, aber ich will fragen, wie es bei euch ist, da ist es halt manchmal so, da wird jetzt gesagt, wir machen jetzt einfach alles digital und das heißt, es wird automatisch davon ausgegangen, die Leute haben zu Hause nicht nur überhaupt die Geräte, sondern sie haben auch Geräte, die jetzt überhaupt alles können, was dazu benötigt wird. Gibt es da bei euch eine Regelung, dass sich Auszubildende, dass sie Technik bekommen können, falls sie die selber nicht haben, weil sie sich das zum Beispiel nicht leisten können? Oder ist das so ein Ding, wo man auch davon ausgeht, das muss eigentlich heutzutage jeder haben? Also geht ihr damit irgendwie um?
Ein gängiges Modell, was ja gerade gefahren wird, sind Tablet-Klassen, und in die Richtung gehen unsere Überlegungen auch.
Also das ihr Geräte anschafft, die ihr dann an die Auszubildenden gebt.
Genau. Da gibt es ja den Unterschied dann auch bei Allgemeinbildenschulen. Also je nach Bundesland, da hat man ja wieder den schönen…
Federativen Gedanken.
Also die Länder verfahren ja unterschiedlich damit. In Niedersachsen ist es beispielsweise so, also ich weiß jetzt hier aus Hannover, dass hier viele elternfinanzierte 1 zu 1-Modelle gefahren werden. In anderen Ländern sind es halt mehr Klassensätze, die da angeschafft werden. Genau, also diese Überlegungen gibt es ja, die gab es ja vorher jetzt auch schon und genau, wir überlegen genau so und versuchen da gerade Lösungen zu finden.
Aber jetzt ist es ja gerade akut, weil die Auszubildenden dürfen nicht mehr in die Schule kommen. Habt ihr da Rückmeldungen bekommen oder hat sich das glücklicherweise irgendwie so ergeben, dass es irgendwie funktioniert?
Also ich habe tatsächlich bei uns von keinem Fall gehört, wo irgendjemand nicht das entsprechende Equipment hatte. Da ist halt irgendwie ein Smartphone. Gut, vielleicht nicht sagen, dass die auch, wie gesagt, keine Schüler mehr sind, sondern eben Ausgebildene und vielleicht ein Unterschied.
Okay, gut, dann ich habe jetzt genug gefragt. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir wissen sollten oder wo du denkst, was du dir wünschen würdest, damit es noch besser funktioniert oder was du mitgeben würdest als Tipp?
Na das Einzige, was mir halt immer total aus der Seele brennt, ist, dass wenn jemand vor mir steht, der irgendwie sagt, ich kriege das nicht hin oder mensch, das traue ich mir nicht mehr ran. Die coolsten Lehrer, die ich halt getroffen habe, waren die, die halt drei Jahre vor der Rente standen und trotzdem gesagt haben, so das ist toll, das will ich trotzdem ausprobieren und ich kann auch noch so viel lernen. Also das ist halt immer so, da freue ich mich persönlich drüber und genauso versuche ich halt eben auch an die Sachen ranzugehen, die ich nicht kenne.
Sehr schön, alles klar, Mirco. Dann vielen Dank.
Ja, danke auch.
Dir einen schönen Abend noch, erfolgreiches digitales Lernen und bleib gesund.
Tschüss.
So, dann haben wir jetzt schon digitale Party gemacht und digitale Bildung haben wir auch schon an den Start gebracht. Dann hören wir jetzt noch ein bisschen Musik und dann geht es mit Telefonen weiter. Was das für eine Rolle spielt, besprechen wir gleich nach. Noch einem Song von TKN vom Album Quest und der Song heißt Missile.
Ich bin gespannt, wie du siehst.
Telefone und ich rede jetzt nicht, ich meine jetzt nicht Smartfone, sondern ich meine jetzt wirklich auch Telefone. Kennt man im Umfeld durch das Chaos Computer Club, weil es, das habt ihr vielleicht, also wenn ihr vom Chaos Communication Kongress wart, habt ihr es gesehen oder selber sogar gemacht. Oder ihr habt zumindest auf Twitter davon gelesen, wenn der Kongress naht, dann fragen nämlich alle Leute nach ihren Deckgeräten. Also diesen altertümlichen Handtelefonen, die man mitnehmen kann, weil die kann man auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress betreiben. Und dahinter steckt eine Gruppe von Leuten, die das machen und die heißt Eventphone und da ist Sascha einer davon. Richtig?
Das ist ganz genau richtig.
Sehr gut so geschrieben. Sagt doch nochmal kurz, was genau und vor allen Dingen warum genau gibt es Eventphone?
Eventphone ist so aus einer Not heraus entstanden, dass wir Hardware hatten und nicht wussten, was wir da sinnvoll mit anfangen sollten und haben die dann auf ein Event mitgenommen. Das war 2001 in Holland, ein Outdoor-Hacker-Camp und da haben wir unsere Anlage mitgenommen und gedacht, da kann man auf dem Event ein bisschen mit rumspielen. Wir können uns so zwei, drei Telefone in unser Zelt stellen und dann können wir uns gegenseitig anrufen. Und das nahm dann direkt sehr, sehr große Ausmaße an, wo wir dann gesagt haben, okay, das wollen auch noch andere Leute haben und dann kamen irgendwie vom Kölner Chaos jemand drüber und meinte, oh, können wir auch so ein Telefon in unserem Zelt haben? Und so hatte dann irgendwann die gesamte Ecke, wo der CCC draufgecampt hat, irgendwie Telefon. Und 2003 für das Camp in Alt Landsberg haben wir uns dann gedacht, da müssen wir was Größeres machen, da müssen wir das allen zur Verfügung stellen und auch vorher direkt sagen, dass es das gibt.
Okay, und seitdem gibt es Handtelefone. So jetzt ist es ja so, dass man sich das, aber auf so einem Event ist es ja dann doch so, man kann sich das eigentlich vorstellen wie eine riesige Basisstation. Und da melden sich halt einfach nicht irgendwie zwei Hand-Sets an, sondern halt, weiß ich nicht, was war auf dem letzten Chaos-Kongress? Wie viele tausend?
Ja, ein paar tausend. Da habe ich jetzt gerade so auf die schnelle keine Zahl. Das kann hier aber nachreichen und wir haben auch die Statistik-Seite.
Jetzt habt ihr, und deswegen bist ihr heute hier, im Rahmen dieses, wir müssen alle zu Hause bleiben und sollen uns, sollen nur distance socialisen, etwas mit Telefon gemacht. Was genau?
Ja, wir haben eine Telefon-Hotline gemacht für ältere Leute. Ich kann ja kurz ein bisschen dazu ausholen, wie das so gekommen ist. Es ist ein gewisser Boris hatte auf Twitter einen Tweet rausgehauen, in dem er meinte, wir helfen jetzt allen Leuten, ist ja ganz toll. Und dieser Nachbarschafts-Challenge ist ja auch total super. Aber was machen jetzt die Leute, die wirklich zu Hause sind, die ältere Menschen, die vielleicht kein Internet haben? Wie kommen die jetzt an diese Hilfsangebote? Wie können die die Leute kontaktieren, die helfen wollen, die ja relativ jung sind oder zumindest ganz gut im Internet verwurzelt sind? Wie kann man die zusammenbringen? Und dann war seine Idee, da müsste man doch eigentlich eine Hotline verbauen, so eine Telefonnummer, mit der man anrufen kann und wo man seinen Hilfegesuch aufgeben kann. Und dieser Tweet hat dann innerhalb von kürzester Zeit riesengroße Wellen geschlagen. Und es wurde ihm ganz, ganz viel Hilfe angeboten aus allen Ecken. Und dann, ich glaube, ich kann das nicht hundertprozentig wiedergeben, wie es genau war, aber ich weiß, dass da auf jeden Fall auch welche von Fridays for Future mit drin waren, die irgendeinen PDF-Generator gemacht haben, womit man so einen Zettel ausdrucken kann für die Hausflure, wo man drauf schreiben kann, hier, wir möchten helfen. Wer braucht Hilfe? Bitte auf den Zettel schreiben. Und er hat dann viele, viele Leute zusammengetragen, um dieses Projekt auf die Beine zu stellen. Und irgendwann kam es halt dazu so, jetzt brauchen wir aber irgendwas, jetzt brauchen wir so eine wirkliche, so eine Hotline. Die hatten bis dahin einen, so einen Anrufbeantworter, so einen Online-Anrufbeantworter, wo halt irgendwelche Nachrichten eingingen. Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal schwierig, gerade für ältere Menschen, die hinterlassen dann fünf Stunden lang ihre ganze Lebensgeschichte und da haben wir gesagt, da müssen wir irgendwie ein bisschen mit helfen. Und dann ist der Boris über ein paar Ecken über den CCC an uns gekommen. Und dann haben wir uns die Anforderungen angehört und gedacht, naja, da müssen wir auf jeden Fall helfen. Das können wir machen.
Wie denn?
Wir haben einen großen Zip-Trunk bekommen, also eine... Halt, was ist ein großer Zip-Trunk? Das ist Voice-over-IP. Das ist quasi eine Telefonnummer, wo ganz, ganz viele Leute gleichzeitig anrufen können. Die geht nicht so als klassische Leitung irgendwie in ein Haus rein, sondern das ist halt so internetbasiert mit Netzwerk hintendran. Das kann man dann beliebig irgendwo hin konfigurieren auf einen Server. Den Server haben wir dann vom CCC bekommen dafür. Und diese, wie gesagt, diese 200 gleichzeitig Leitungen, die man anrufen kann, die wurden gesponsert, soweit ich das weiß. Und dann haben wir uns daran gemacht, zu überlegen, was macht man am sinnvollsten für diese Hotline? Boris hatte auch irgendwie in seinem Team schon rum überlegt, was macht man so? Gibt man ihnen ein Auswahlmenü? Und dann haben wir kurz, das war an einem, ich gucke jetzt nochmal gerade nach, es war vorletzte Woche Sonntag. Am 15.3. kam dieser Hilferuf zu uns, hier, ihr müsst uns irgendwie helfen. Wir haben hier so eine Nummer und wir haben aber keine Ahnung, wie wir da jetzt sinnvoll eine Hotline hinten dran kriegen. Und außerdem müssen wir mit den Daten die Schnittstelle von nebenan.de befüllen. Und da haben wir gesagt, naja, das können wir bestimmt irgendwie stemmen, haben uns kurz zusammengefunden, also virtuell zusammengefunden. Und dann innerhalb von tatsächlich 42 Minuten, wir haben dann geguckt, irgendwie als der erste Anruf funktionierte, haben wir innerhalb von 42 Minuten einen kompletten Server, die ganze Infrastruktur aufgesetzt. Einer hat einen Mail-Server konfiguriert, der nächste hat das Monitoring eingebaut, der nächste hat Backup auf der Kiste installiert. Die Skripte wurden geschrieben, dass die Telefonanlage, die auf diesem Server läuft, die wurde konfiguriert. Und das haben wir irgendwie alles so mehr oder weniger in 40 bis 42 Minuten so hinbekommen. Und dann gab es den ersten Anruf. Ja, wir waren selber überrascht, aber wir haben gedacht, okay, jetzt können wir anrufen, wie lange haben wir den jetzt gebraucht? Wie lange ist denn diese virtuelle Maschine jetzt schon an? Und ich weiß nicht, die 42 ist ja in den Kreisen auch recht bekannt und es waren tatsächlich wirklich 42 Minuten.
Aber das heißt sozusagen, normalerweise installiert man irgendwas und denkt, naja gut, das wird nicht sofort funktionieren. In diesem Fall hat es das getan.
Es hat das fast sofort getan. Wir haben natürlich noch über die Tage danach immer wieder noch Änderungen gemacht. Der Text wurde drei- viermal umgeworfen. Ich habe dann angeboten, weil ich auch ein Studio habe, dass ich den Text einspreche dafür. Der wurde dann zwei- dreimal neu gemacht. Und dann mussten noch Rechtsanwälte drüber gucken. Und dann musste das noch irgendwie überlegt werden, wie diese Datenübergabe nach nebenan.de funktioniert. Aber letztendlich haben wir das dann alles zusammenbekommen. Und der aktuelle Ablauf sieht jetzt so aus, man ruft diese Rufnummer an. Kann man auch auf gemeinschaft.online die Rufnummer sehen. Da ist auch nochmal ein bisschen erklärt, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Dann ruft man da an, man bekommt ein Auswahlmenü, gibt seine Postleitzahl ein. Das ist relativ wichtig, damit nebenan.de diese Hilfegesuche auch in die entsprechenden Bereiche schieben kann, wo Leute helfen wollen.
Ich habe das schon ein paar Mal gehört, aber weiß nicht ganz genau.
Nebenan.de ist so ein großes Nachbarschaftsnetzwerk, wo man sich registrieren kann und kann in seiner lokalen Umgebung Leute um Hilfe bitten oder kann den Leuten Sachen anbieten. Ich brauche eine Bohrmaschine in Kreuzberg oder so. Oder ich brauche was auch immer, jemanden, der mir im Garten hilft oder der eine Hecke schneiden kann. Dann können die Nachbarn aus dem direkten Umland diese Gesuche sehen und darauf antworten. Das ist ja für Leute, die Internet haben, überhaupt kein Problem. Allerdings in der zu erwartenden Notlage, wenn dann wirklich ältere Menschen Hilfe brauchen, die brauchen Leute, die für sie einkaufen, dann haben die jetzt die Möglichkeit, einfach diese Rufnummer anzurufen. Die tippen ihre Postleitzahl ein und dann können sie aus vier Kategorien auswählen, wo sie Hilfe bei benötigen. Ob beim Einkaufen oder bei Hunden oder Tieren im Allgemeinen. Ob sie irgendwas repariert haben möchten oder dann gibt es auch noch den Punkt Sonstiges. Und dann haben wir zusätzlich noch eine Partnerschaft mit dieser Rufnummer mit dem Silbernetz e.V. Das ist eine Gruppe von freiwilligen, von ehrenamtlichen Menschen, die tagsüber am Telefon sitzen und Anrufe entgegennehmen. Und mit denen kann man einfach mal quatschen, wenn man mit denen reden möchte. Das heißt, gegen Altersarm, Einsamkeit oder sowas hilft das. Und das wird auch sehr gut angenommen. Wir haben uns gedacht, wenn wir keine Rückrufnummer haben von den Leuten, die anrufen, von den älteren Menschen, dann müssen wir denen ja trotzdem irgendwie helfen. Und deswegen werden die dann z.B. zu Silbernetz durchgestellt. Da sitzen dann Menschen und die können dann im Zweifelsfall diese Informationen entgegennehmen.
Warte mal, man ruft da an und dann klickt man sich sozusagen durch, was man will?
Ganz genau.
Gibt seine Postleitzahl ein und kriegt dann genau was zurück.
Dann bekommt man die Info, dass die Anfrage weitergeleitet wird an nebenan.de. Und da wird die dann als Hilfegesuch eingestellt. Und wenn man auf nebenan.de sagt, ich möchte dieser Person helfen, also man sieht das halt nur, wenn man auch in der Region wohnt.
Warte, das wird eingestellt. Was heißt das? Das wird sozusagen aus diesem, er hat Taste 1 für Einkaufen gedrückt und die Postleitzahl ist 18397. Daraus wurde ein automatischer Textbaustein generiert und als Anzeige ausgelöst.
Ganz genau, das ist so eine Hilfe-Gesuch-Anzeige. Da steht dann drin, in deinem Postleitzahlenbereich 1-5 braucht jemand Hilfe beim Einkaufen. Und als nebenan.de Mitglied kann man dann sagen, der Person möchte ich helfen. Und dann bekommt man eine E-Mail mit der Telefonnummer von der Person. Und dann kann man die anrufen und dann kann man fragen, ja, wie sieht genau die Hilfe aus? Was kann ich tun? Was wird benötigt? Und dann wird der Person geholfen. Stand heute haben wir 378 Anrufe bisher vermittelt. Und davon sind 190 Richtung Silbernetz abgebogen. Die wollten halt mit jemandem Echten sprechen.
Und gibt es auch schon Erkenntnisse, wie das dann funktioniert? Also wie das funktioniert hat, ob da Hilfe zustande gekommen ist?
Das haben wir bisher noch keinen Feedback bekommen. Das wird man wahrscheinlich mal so in ein, zwei Tagen nochmal gucken können, wenn da noch ein bisschen mehr drauf geht. Also die Last ist jetzt noch nicht allzu hoch. Das ist ja auch ein gutes Zeichen. Wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt über den Zeitraum von anderthalb Wochen ungefähr 380 Anrufe bekommen, wo Leute im Menü irgendwie was ausgewählt haben. Und viel mehr sehen wir auch nicht. Wir schieben dann, sobald dieser Anruf fertig ist, geben wir diese Informationen halt weiter an nebenan.de und die verarbeiten diese Daten dann. Und machen daraus die Anzeigen. Wir haben also nur einen kleinen, einen klitzekleinen Teil davon gebaut. Da sind ja noch viel, viel mehr Leute drum herum beteiligt. Es gibt irgendwie Leute, die die Webseite dafür gemacht haben. Es wurde ein Fernsehwerbespot produziert dafür. Auf der Webseite? Ja, ja, es gibt einen richtigen Werbespot, wo eine von den ehrenamtlichen Mitarbeiterinnen von Silbernetz, die uns halt, da hat uns geholfen, diesen Werbespot zu machen. Es gibt ganz, ganz viele Leute, die das gemacht haben. Es gibt eine große Liste auf gemeinschaft.online. Wenn ich die jetzt alle aufzähle, das kann eh keiner behalten. Aber da gibt es eine tolle Liste, wo man sehen kann, wer uns wirklich alles geholfen hat. Und das auch in kürzester Zeit, wo wirklich viele, viele Menschen, über 100 Leute, daran gearbeitet haben, gemeinschaftlich.
Immer friedlich zusammen, Entschuldigung, dass ich das fragen muss. Aber es ist ja so, wenn technische Projekte aus dem Boden gestampft werden, mit sehr vielen Beteiligten, das ist ja manchmal auch schwierig.
Das hat eigentlich recht gut geklappt. Wir hatten am Anfang natürlich so die üblichen Kommunikationsprobleme, weil wir kannten uns noch gar nicht. Also wir kannten Boris nicht. Boris kannte uns nur vom Kongress. Und die machen da dieses Telefon. Das war so sein Eindruck, was er kannte. Aber das war, ich glaube, das war nach zwei, drei Stunden, war das Problem gegessen. Und dann waren die Sachen klar, die Anforderungen waren klar. Und dann haben wir darunter implementiert.
Cool. Hört sich gut an. Die war es das jetzt? Also quasi ist das fertig im Sinne von, ihr habt das jetzt gebaut und jetzt funktioniert das. Super gutes Ding. Oder sind noch Dinge geplant?
Also sind noch so ein paar Dinge geplant. Es gibt noch wohl Anverragen vom Roten Kreuz, glaube ich. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Es gibt auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Anfragen, die da auch Probleme mit ihren aktuellen Hotlines haben. Es gibt ja auch noch so ein paar andere Hotlines in diesem Land, die aktuell nicht so gut funktionieren. Und die sind wohl auch schon an Boris herangetreten. Und jetzt gucken wir, dass wir so die Anforderungen einsammeln, was die haben wollen. Und dann überlegen wir uns, ob wir das nochmal wieder realisieren können.
Woran scheitert das?
Ich glaube tatsächlich an den Strukturen, die nicht vorhanden sind. Also jetzt als Beispiel die Telefonnummer für die Arbeitsagentur, diese Hotline, die es da gibt. Ich glaube, die ist lokal organisiert. Und da sitzen jetzt einfach keine Leute aktuell, weil viele von denen wahrscheinlich Homeoffice machen. Also das sind jetzt alles nur Vermutungen. Aber das ist halt einfach nicht dafür ausgelegt, dass das in dieser Größenordnung skaliert, wenn auf einmal wie viele Hunderttausend Menschen jetzt Angst um ihren Job haben, weil sie in irgendeinem Restaurant arbeiten, was geschlossen ist. Oder wo auch immer sie arbeiten, was gerade nicht offen ist. Und wenn sie dann da nur nicht festangestellt sind und so, dann stehen die halt jetzt auf der Straße. Wenn die halt das Arbeitsamt anrufen wollen und da geht keiner ran über Wochen, das ist natürlich irgendwie auch nicht besonders toll. Und wenn man dann wenigstens die Möglichkeit hätte, keine Ahnung, so eine Art Ticket aufzumachen. Wie gesagt, die Ideen sind da vielfältig. Wenn wir genau wissen, was benötigt wird und wir dann in unserem Rahmen da helfen können, dann machen wir das super gerne.
Wie finanziert ihr das eigentlich? Also sammelt ihr da auch Spenden ein oder seid ihr aus der Kategorie, ich verdiene in meinem normalen IT-Job so gut, dass ich jetzt hier einfach so arbeiten kann?
Irgendwer muss es ja machen.
Aber irgendwer muss trotzdem auch essen.
Richtig, ja. Wir haben alle einen Day-Job. Wir arbeiten alle irgendwie mehr oder weniger in der IT-Branche. Deswegen geht es uns im Moment auch noch ganz okay. Weil IT kann halt eigentlich immer arbeiten, zumindest was das angeht. Aber die eigentlichen Leute bei uns, die machen das so nebenher. Es muss halt gemacht werden. Und wir haben Ahnung davon, das war jetzt für uns keine große, also als wir die Anforderungen gehört haben wir gesagt, ach so, naja gut, das kann man ja mal schnell machen. Ich habe hier etwas vorbereitet. Der Server selber, den hat der CCC dann bezahlt. Das sind irgendwie auch ein paar Euro nur im Monat. Das sind keine großen Posten. Und für sowas, was tatsächlich Menschen hilft, da muss man das einfach mal auf sich nehmen.
Sehr, sehr cool. Braucht ihr noch Hilfe? Kann man da noch irgendwas tun?
Also man kann sich bestimmt bei Boris noch melden, wenn man irgendwie mithelfen will. Es gibt ja jetzt vielleicht dann nochmal in Zukunft Projekte, wo irgendwie Dinge getan werden müssen. Ich werde auch den Tweet auf jeden Fall nochmal mit in die Show Notes packen bzw. ich schicke dir den und dann kannst du den rein machen. Da kann man mit Sicherheit nochmal Bezug drauf nehmen und dann gibt es da bestimmt auch noch wieder weitere Hilfegesuche, wenn da nochmal was benötigt wird.
Sehr schön. Cool. Die Gemeinschaftspunkt online ist die Webseite zu dem Projekt. Könnt ihr da rauf gucken. Und wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der Hilfe braucht, dem ihr nicht selber helfen könnt, dann gebt ihm diese Adresse. Vielleicht hilft das ja. Nicht schlecht. Dann bleibt gesund und viel Spaß noch.
Danke ebenfalls.
Bis dann. Tschüss. So, dann haben wir jetzt Party gemacht, Bildung gemacht, den einsamen Menschen am Telefon geholfen und reden gleich mal darüber, wie es eigentlich mit der Videoverbreitung durch das VOC, also dem Videoverbreitungszentrum des Chaos Computer Clubs, funktioniert. Vorher noch eine letzte kleine Musik von TKN, die auch von dem Album Quest kommt und in diesem Fall einfach Quest auch heißt. Das war TKN nochmal mit Quest im Chaosradio 258, wo wir jetzt noch ein letztes Thema haben bei digitale Alternativen zu Dingen, die man vor der Krise analog gemacht hat, aber jetzt nicht mehr so richtig gehen. Und da zählen auch Chaosveranstaltungen zu. Also es gibt ja nicht nur den Chaos Communication Congress, es gibt ja auch viele kleinere Dinge oder Dinge, die zu anderen Terminen passieren. Und da gab es schon immer eine Kultur von hey, lass uns doch auch live per Video übertragen. Aber jetzt ist es ja gerade so, dass diese Dinge einfach nicht stattfinden können. Und die Frage ist, was passiert jetzt und welche Rolle kann das VOC dabei spielen? Und dazu ist Danimo jetzt bei mir. Hallo und guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
So, wie findet das denn jetzt alles statt? Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist das nächste Chaos Event, also was jetzt als nächstes passiert wäre, aber nicht passiert?
Das nächste wäre das Easter Egg gewesen und danach die GPN und dann noch viele kleine andere Events und Jugendhackt und weiß ja gar nicht alles. Also unsere Liste ist lang, auch auf der Seite von VOC unter c3voc.de einzusehen übrigens. Und diese Liste ist jetzt doch ganz beträchtlich geschrumpft. Und gleichzeitig sind halt die Leute, die sonst Vorträge gehalten hätten und die Leute, die diese Veranstaltung gerne besucht hätten, alle auf die gleiche Idee gekommen, nämlich lass mal das VOC anschreiben. Ob die da nicht was steichseln können.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn ich den Anfang der Sendung nehme, also United We Stream, wir machen einfach den DJ ohne Leute, das wäre doch exakt auch dasselbe gewesen dann, oder nicht?
Genau, also die Idee liegt ja sehr nahe. Die hatten wir, die hatten also wirklich viele andere auch. Das Einzige ist, es ist für uns, so wie wir sonst arbeiten, so ein bisschen unbetretenes Territorium. Weil normalerweise sind wir halt irgendwo vor Ort und haben da irgendwie gesichert Internet und irgendwie alles ist so ein bisschen wenigstens planbar. Wenn Leute jetzt aus ihrem Wohnzimmer oder aus ihrem Arbeitszimmer oder sonst wo streamen, um sozusagen ihren Vortrag zu halten, um ihr Projekt drüber zu bringen, dann stehen wir ja vor ganz anderen Herausforderungen. Nämlich wir kennen die, wir wissen nicht, wie die Leute angebunden sind, wie zuverlässig das funktioniert. Also gerade jetzt unter den Bedingungen des Corona-Shutdowns, Netzbetreiber zittern um ihre Ressourcen, Streamingdienste reduzieren, Bandbreiten.
Warte mal, warte mal, ich möchte kurz den Ausflug machen, der Hoffnung, dass du ein bisschen informierter bist als ich. Ich habe das auch gelesen, die Schlagzeile bei Netflix macht weniger Bandbreite. Habe aber auch gelesen, das ist eigentlich Quatsch und überflüssig. Wie ist es denn jetzt wirklich? Also ich merke, ich meine zu merken, dass das Internet wackeliger ist als sonst. Das kann aber auch daran liegen, dass ich Kunde einer Firma bin, die Zahlen im Namen hat.
Also grundsätzlich erst mal nein. Es kriselt, es kriselt aber mehr, je dichter man zum Endbenutzer kommt. Weil die klassische Planung ist halt irgendwie alles klar. Wir haben irgendwie so und so viele Kunden. Wir können ungefähr planen, wann welche Auslastung ist. Und wir können halt locker mehr Kunden auf die Infrastruktur nehmen, als die Infrastruktur eigentlich abkann. Das nennt sich Oversubscription. Und das ist ja an sich erst mal kein Problem, weil man halt weiß, dass nicht jeder seine, keine Ahnung, 100 Megabit, 200 Megabit, 500 Megabit, weiß ja gar ja was, tatsächlich auch abruft. Und dann kalkulieren die das halt alle und dann wird halt auch heftig überbrucht. Und das ist so ein bisschen, wie man das von Flugzeugen vielleicht kennt. Wer fliegt oder so, da passiert es ja auch mal, dass man irgendwie nicht mitfliegen kann, weil sie gesagt haben, ihren Platz haben wir leider vergeben, weil wir gehen davon aus, dass so und so viel Prozent der Leute nicht zum Flug auftauchen.
Okay, das heißt deswegen wackelt es jetzt vielleicht manchmal?
Ja, und wegen Gegebenheiten von Übertragungstechniken. Also wir haben glaube ich mal einen großen Teil einer Chaosradio-Sendung über die Vor- und Nachteile von DSL und Kabel und solche Übertragungstechnologien packen wir in die Show Notes verbracht. Will ich hier nicht wiederholen. Also es sind einige anfälliger dafür, andere weniger, weil man sich teilweise irgendwie so ein Kabel mit mehreren hundert Leuten teilt und dann kann man sich schon vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen schwierig wird.
Okay, ihr wisst also nicht, wenn da jetzt jemand per Video einen Vortrag halten will, wie ist der angebunden? Kann man das vorher irgendwie testen? Also klar kann man sozusagen einen anecdotischen Test machen, aber kann man irgendwie sicherstellen, dass das dann auch hält, was es versprochen hat?
Nö. Naja, das ist halt der Unterschied zwischen irgendwie einem Firmenanschluss, wo jemand kommt und dir eine Faser legt und dann auch die technische Infrastruktur bereitstellt, dass diese, keine Ahnung, 200 Megabit, der eine Gigabit wirklich für dich anliegen und irgendwie...
Ja, das ist schon klar, aber es geht ja darum, was macht man dann damit, wenn man so einen Vortrag... Gibt es dann die Möglichkeit, dass man sagt, naja, pass mal auf, solange es irgendwie reicht von der Bandbreite, machen wir ein richtiges Video, stellst du eine Kamera, machst deine Webcam vielleicht an. Wenn nicht, dann kannst du vielleicht so Slides zeigen, weil dann steht das Bild still und es dann verbraucht weniger Bandbreite. Oder wie klärt ihr das dann?
Genau, also wir arbeiten jetzt an einem Konzept, das uns sozusagen so ein bisschen gegen solche Probleme feiert, was also möglichst universal einsetzbar ist, wo man also sagen kann, okay, ich traue mich hier gar nichts, ich zeichne meinen Vortrag halt auf und ihr nehmt das dann irgendwie zur gegebenen Zeit in eine Sendeschleife mit rein. Oder wie wir machen das live und wenn das wackelt, dann zeichne ich, dann wird das nochmal beim Vortragen dann aufgezeichnet. Da läuft einfach ein Recording mit und dann sehen wir ja sozusagen, was das bringt. Und das sind alles so Überlegungen, die wir gerade anstellen. Und unterm Strich müssen wir es halt ausprobieren. Wir sind da gerade noch in der sehr, sehr frühen Probierphase. Deswegen haben wir auch noch nicht so viele Ergebnisse. Aber wichtig sind halt auch so Vollüberlegungen, die wir gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel, wenn man das jetzt so kennt, also die erste Überlegung war so, lass halt irgendwie so so Jitsi nehmen oder wie sie nicht alle heißen, also so klassische Software, die man für Meetings nimmt. Und das ist halt nicht so clever, weil eigentlich will man ja nur einem zugucken. Und eigentlich braucht der auch nicht die Slides uns seine Kamera schicken, sondern der kann uns eigentlich schon ein fertiges Signal schicken. Weil dann schwarmen wir nochmal Bandbreite. Das ist halt alles zu Überlegungen.
Ist das nicht schon eine große Herausforderung, dass man der Vortragende dann nicht nur Vortrag halten muss, sondern auch noch Bildregie führen soll?
Das wollen wir halt eben so weit wie möglich abnehmen. Also dadurch, dass wir quasi fertige Konfix abliefern, dass wir sagen, alles klar, wir sagen dir genau, wie du dich vorbereiten kannst, wie du mit bestehenden Mitteln erst mal ein möglichst gutes Bild hinkriegst und möglichst wenig Probleme bekommst. Das nimmt dir schon mal Stress. Und indem wir sagen, wenn du dich auf deinen Vortrag konzentrieren willst, dann nimmst du diese Einstellung, drückst auf Stream und dann hältst du deinen Vortrag. Und um alles andere kümmern wir uns.
Du hast ja, ihr liefert dem eine Software an oder der?
Genau, das ist, wir arbeiten im Moment oder wir experimentieren im Moment mit OBS, das ist ja so das, was in der Streaming-Szene so klassischerweise viele Leute hernehmen. Und da kann man Presets quasi einstellen. Und dieses Preset kann man einfach an die Vortragenden verschicken.
Also OBS ist eine Software, wo man Bildquellen reinwerfen kann. Also man kann seine Spielkonsole an eine HDMI-Hardware anschließen, die das als Signal übersetzt. Oder man kann sagen Webcam und die Software kann auch von alleine Bild in Bild. Also man kann sagen hier, das ist die eine Bildquelle, das ist die andere Bildquelle. Okay, ich verstehe. Ihr liefert nicht die Software, ihr sagt, ladet die Software runter. Dann gibt es von euch sozusagen eine Konfigurationsdatei. Und wenn man das beides zusammen ausgeführt hat, dann kann man im Prinzip wenig falsch machen.
Das ist so die Idee an der ganzen Geschichte. Genau, also wie gesagt, die Validierung steht noch aus. Aber das, was wir bisher damit probiert haben, so für uns, sieht erst mal ganz gut aus. Man erreicht damit auch eine Qualität, die dort sehr akzeptabel ist.
Ich muss trotzdem noch Sachen fragen. Vielleicht sagst du dann, nein, das wissen wir noch nicht. Aber ich glaube, das sind trotzdem Probleme, die man sprechen sollte. Das eine ist, das ist ja dann immer ein Vortrag. Aber das Schöne an einer Veranstaltung ist ja, dass die eine Dramaturgie hat im Zweifelsfall. Also gibt es dann noch eine weitere Videozuspielquelle, wo jemand das moderiert. Und wer sorgt denn dafür, dass diese Videos auch nahtlos ineinander in der gehen? Also habt ihr sozusagen so eine Art War Room, wo ihr dann sitzt und Regler umlegt?
Naja, das mit dem War Room scheitert ja schon daran. Ein War Room möchte ja gerne von mehreren Leuten bespielt werden.
Ha, schwierig. Im Internet, im Internet.
Im Internet, Marcus, dass du es ansprichst. Also in diesem Internet installieren wir also eine virtuelle Maschine, auf der noch mal eine, bis jetzt gehen wir davon aus, dass wir da auch OBS für nehmen werden, also noch eine OBS-Instance laufen wird, die wiederum diese ganzen Streams annehmen wird. Und die funktioniert so ein bisschen wie so eine zentrale Senderabwicklung bei einem klassischen Fernsehsender. Das heißt, dort laufen die ganzen Signale auf und wenn eine Vortragende fertig ist, können wir auf den anderen übergehen oder wir geben eine Pausenschleife drauf oder wir geben einen Herald drauf, der solange bis der nächste Vortragende am Start ist, ein bisschen gute Laune verbreitet und ein paar Infos verteilt. Also das sind alles so Ideen, mit denen wir spielen, was natürlich auch so ein bisschen eine Herausforderung ist, weil du kennst es ja wahrscheinlich auch aus deinem Tagesjob. Du musst irgendwie vorher mit den Leuten reden können. Du musst sie vorbereiten, dass sie gleich dran sind. Du musst irgendwie eine Art Übergabe hinkriegen.
Was mich vor allem die Frage ist, das ist ja bei Audio schon kompliziert genug, aber Audio hat den Vorteil, dass es so schmal ist vom Datenverbrauch, dass es relativ instantan ist. Wenn ich mich an meine Versuche erinnere, per eben dieser OBS-Software Videospiel-Dinge zu streamen, dann ist der Lack, bevor das auf der Webseite ankommt, so 30 Sekunden bis eine Minute. Das heißt, wenn ich Chat-Nachrichten lese, beziehen sie sich auf etwas, was in meiner Welt schon eine Minute vorbei ist. Das macht auch ein ganz großes Problem bei solchen Übergängen. Wenn ich jetzt der nächste Vortragende bin, dann muss ich ja schon eine Minute angefangen haben, bevor der Moderator, der mich ankündigt, fertig ist. Das heißt, gibt es Mittel für Kommunikation? Wie gibt man jemanden das Signal, jetzt musst du loslegen?
Ja, also da gibt es mehrere Strategien. Also ich will erst mal darauf eingehen, warum das überhaupt eine Minute bei dir dauert. Und zwar das Ganze läuft nochmal bei deinem Streaming-Anbieter durch so eine Kaskade von Servern. Das dauert einfach ein bisschen. Und außerdem funktioniert die Art und Weise, wie das ausgespielt wird, so dass du viele kleine Schnipsel hast, viele kleine Videoschnipsel. Die wird dann in so einer Art Playliste ausgeliefert. Da gibt es zwei Standards. Der eine heißt HLS, das ist das, was Apple macht. Der andere heißt Dash. Das ist das, was alle anderen machen. Aber die setzen halt voraus, dass du erstmal so ein paar Schnipsel... Dass du erstmal so ein paar Schnipsel...
Für mein Verständnis. Das heißt, das anderthalbstündige Streaming-Video von Diablo, das ich rausgeschickt habe, ist gar kein anderthalbstündiges Video im Livestream, sondern im Prinzip eine Ansammlung von kurzen Videos, die aber nacheinander so ausgeliefert werden, dass es für mich wie ein langes Video aussieht?
Genau, das macht dein Player. Und der Vorteil daran ist, dein Player kann darauf reagieren, dass zum Beispiel die Bandbreite knapp wird und der Server liefert dir nicht nur verschiedene Schnipsel aus, sondern sagt auch, pass mal auf, wenn gerade die Bandbreite ein bisschen dünn ist, dann nimm doch diese Datei statt der Datei und die ist dann vielleicht nicht mehr Full HD und sieht auch ein bisschen matcher aus, aber dafür bleibst du wenigstens am Spiel und am Zeitrand ohne, dass dieser berühmte Buffering kommt. Genau, aber das ist eines der Gründe, das ist nicht unbedingt der zentrale Grund, aber das ist mit eines der Gründe, weswegen du immer so eine Verzögerung hast. Und da derjenige, der das dann an uns schickt, quasi das nicht über dieses Verfahren macht, sagen wir mal, hast du vielleicht eine Sekundelatenz, zwei. Aber klar, der Rückkanal, der irgendwie ihm sagt, pass auf, jetzt kann es losgehen, das müssen wir anders realisieren. Da wird er wahrscheinlich ein Knopf ins Ohr kriegen. Also nimmt sich irgendwie sein Headset und da läuft dann ein Mumble drauf. Also das sind so Ideen, die wir im Moment haben. Oder ganz banal Text, Chat, IRC, das ist ja quasi auch instantan.
Was das Schöne an Chaos veranstaltet ist, ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht auf so vielen außer auf dem Kongress, tut mir leid. Aber beim Kongress ist ja was ganz Krasses und auch Selbstorganisiertes, dass viele Vorträge auch noch simultan übersetzt werden.
Ja, da haben sich auch die Übersetzer schon gemeldet, also das Translation Team und da arbeiten wir auch noch an Lösungen. Also das ist vorsichtig geplant. Ich kann da noch nichts genaues sagen, weil ich mich in den Planungen tatsächlich noch nicht rein gefuchst habe. Im Zweifelsfall wird es wieder sowas geben wie ein Mumble, wo man sich zusätzlich reinklinken kann, so wie das in den Vortrags-Sellen war. Wenn es richtig gut läuft, kriegen wir es vielleicht auch hin, das mit dem ganz normalen Stream auszuliefern. Aber wenn dann die Verzögerung so doof wird, dass man quasi den Kontext gar nicht mitbekommt, weil da irgendwie mehrere Sekunden dazwischen sind, also mehr als man es jetzt hätte, wenn man das klassisch auf dem Kongress hat, dann dauert es ja auch mal ein bisschen, bis der Simultanübersetzer dann wirklich hinterherkommt. Und wenn dann noch mal zusätzlich Verzögerung raufkommt, dann ist es das irgendwann nicht mehr wert. Und dann muss man sich halt überlegen, dass man zumindest für das Livestreaming an sich erst mal, das dann vielleicht noch auf einer anderen Technik macht. Aber wie gesagt, da arbeiten wir noch dran. Und es ist auf jeden Fall auf unserem Radar.
So, das hört sich jetzt alles ein bisschen nach an. Es gibt die schönen Ideen. Aber wann können wir denn das vielleicht zum ersten Mal beobachten?
Du erinnerst dich, dass ich sagte, zum Beispiel ist das Easter Hack ausgefallen und anstelle aller die Zuhören und sich interessieren für ein Online-Event, das so, wie ich das gerade beschrieben habe, eventuell stattfinden könnte, die sollten sich Ostern mal vielleicht nichts vornehmen.
Okay, braucht man denn noch Hilfe?
Im Moment basteln wir selber erst mal so vor uns hin mit den bestehenden Leuten, weil es einfach gerade eine Frage von Zeit ist. Ich bewundere Sascha immer wieder und überhaupt die ganze Eventphone-Crew, wie sie sozusagen Zeit finden. Ich habe halt auch noch einen Tagesjob, das geht anderen auch so. Aber je näher dann quasi die gesetzte Deadline kommt, umso schneller gehen dann auch klassischerweise Dinge. Es ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, wenn Leute kommen und ihre Hilfe anbieten, dann finden wir das grundsätzlich immer ganz klasse. Das Problem ist immer so ein bisschen, wir arbeiten ein bisschen wie Broadcast-Leute, wir arbeiten ein bisschen wie ITler. Aber meistens kommen die Leute entweder von der einen oder von der anderen Seite und müssen sich das andere quasi erst angucken. Das ist in der konkreten Situation. Wir laufen auf ein Event so immer schwierig. Deswegen generell sind wir immer total dafür, dass sich Leute sozusagen unsere Technik angucken und uns auch helfen oder Teil des VOCs werden. Aber idealerweise nie im näheren Zulauf auf ein Event, weil das wird dann immer schwierig und das ist dann auch immer doof, die Leute zu enttäuschen, weil sie dann möglicherweise nicht das tun können, was sie sich erhofft haben, dass sie tun können.
Das hört sich so ein bisschen an nach wie rufen sie uns nicht an, wie rufen sie an.
Nee, im Gegenteil, also klassischerweise würde ich immer sagen, kommt zu kleineren Events. Das ist hier halt ein bisschen schwierig gerade. Also klassischerweise lesen wir Leute immer oder schicken wir Leute immer gezielt zu kleineren Events, weil wir dann auch wirklich Zeit haben, uns darum zu kümmern. Hier würde ich sagen analog, wenn wir das erste Event geflogen haben, dann ist es optimal. Was nicht heißt, dass Leute uns nicht schreiben können und nicht sich anbieten können. Also wir haben auch eine Mailing-Liste, video.list.ccc.de, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Fragen, Hilfe anbieten, schadet nie. Es geht nur so ein bisschen darum, dann quasi die große Enttäuschung da direkt rauszunehmen.
Na gut, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das wird.
Ich auch.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage. Das Chaosradio ist in den letzten Sendungen immer mit Bild gewesen. Das ist ja heute nicht so. Darin auch gearbeitet.
Selbes Problem, würde ich sagen, also selbes Problem. Schauen wir mal. Ich wäre sehr dafür, wenn wir das Problem nicht mehr hätten, bis so zeitnah. Aber ich fürchte, das wird uns noch ein bisschen erhalten bleiben. Und insofern, wir arbeiten dran.
Alles klar, das machen wir. Sehr schön, dann Danimo, vielen Dank. Wir sind gespannt, was da noch kommen wird. Und auch dir bleibt gesund und bis bald. So, das war dann schon das Chaos Radio 258 gesendet aus den Stay-At-Home-Studios. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich habe versucht, durch die Sendung zu führen. Falls ihr noch ein tolles Projekt habt, das ihr jetzt kennengelernt habt, wo ihr sagt, hey, das ist auch super, das ist auch eine digitale Alternative zum analogen Leben, das uns gerade verwehrt bleibt, schreibt es uns in die Kommentare oder schreibt es uns an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und dann können wir es vielleicht noch mal irgendwo unterbringen. Mal schauen, wie lange uns das jetzt noch sozusagen weiter ereilt, auch wenn das gemein klingt. Ich hoffe ja, die Arbeit, die sich das VOC zum Beispiel macht, ist umsonst. Ich glaube es nicht, aber schön wäre es eigentlich schon. Gut, damit entlassen wir euch jetzt in den nächsten Monaten, dann hören wir uns wieder. Wir haben noch eine letzte Musik und mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.